bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur sociaux locaux pour la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui j'ai une invitée avec moi
sur la chaîne il s'agit de charlotte
charlotte qui tient le compte instagram
une peinture une histoire je vous mets
le lien dans la barre d'infos
elle présente sur ce compte des oeuvres
d'art avec à chaque fois une anecdote
qui issus à la fois des avis personnels
ou une anecdote historique
est ce que tu peux nous en dire un peu
plus sur ton compte c'est un compte
instagram que j'ai créée en janvier 2020
est en fait j'avais envie de réunir
toutes les peintures que j'ai vu et qui
m'ont procuré des sensations des
émotions
au fil de ces dernières années donc en
fait ça faisait plusieurs années que dès
que voilà il y avait une peinture qui me
kim émouvait beaucoup bajeux là notait
sur sur un petit carnet soit sur mon
téléphone et donc j'avais comme ça des
listes qui s'accumulaient et je me suis
dit il ya plus d'un an j'aimerais
regrouper tous ses tableaux sur un
compte instagram et puis petit à petit
les publier et puis raconter une
histoire autour de ce tableau où
l'histoire du contexte dans lequel j'ai
découvert ou l'histoire du peintre ou de
la peintre ou où la thématique le
tableau aborde ou sur le mouvement
donc voilà le fait d'avoir charlotte sur
la chaîne aujourd'hui ça va nous
permettre de parler d'un aspect de la
sociologie que j'aurais pas aborder sans
charlotte qui est tout ce qui touche à
allart à la question de la beauté de
l'esthétique des normes artistique mais
aussi va de la socialisation comment on
arrive à découvrir le milieu de l'art en
tant qu'enfants et s'était même pas
comme moi je n'ai pas abordés sans la
présence de charlotte
donc on va pouvoir parler de tout ça sur
le modèle d'une discussion assez libre
qu'on va des pieds tout petit pour
comment cette vidéo je trouvais que ça
pouvait être intéressant que si nous
raconte un petit peu de son rapport à
l'art et notamment comment tu es entré
dans voilà
le monde de la culture de l'art et serra
si c'est par exemple quelque chose qui
est présent chez tes parents s'est
agrandie avec ça aussi tu l'a découvert
plus tard oui alors j'ai complètement
grandi avec ça parce que il faut savoir
que ma mère est passionné d'art et de
peinture
mon père est musicien donc voilà j'ai
baigné dans le monde de l'art avec un
grand a
depuis que je suis toute petite et ma
mère enfin j'habitais en fumée à paris
et ma mère depuis tout petit avec ma
soeur elle nous a toujours emmenée aux
expositions après quand mon frère et mes
nous a aussi beaucoup toujours emmenée
au musée fin de chaque mercredi on
allait visiter des choses donc soit
c'était un monument soit c'était ça on
allait à la ville est par exemple
parfois on aller dans des endroits plus
pour les enfants et d'autres fois plus
dans des musées un petit peu plus
académique institutionnels et ma mère
elle m'a toujours voilà parler des
tableaux avec tellement de passion et l
matane ont toujours raconter les
histoires derrière voilà les débats ses
tableaux que mouassa massama ça m'a plu
et ça m'a permis d'aborder facilement
des sujets ou par là quelque chose qui
peut un petit peu sembler peut-être
parfois trop intellectuel ou hors de
portée pour pour d'autres personnes
on a eu ce complexe en grandissant de
réaliser que tu as bien c'est parfois
leur pesant d'or ce retard en culture
générale mais quand on arrive à des
études supérieures par exemple toi tu es
tu as jamais ressenti ça quand tu es
arrivé en hausse et supérieur non au
contraire je trouve que bah ça c'est
intéressant de parler de ça mais je
trouve que justement je me suis plus
senti un petit peu complexé de moins
connaître des choses et par exemple si
je me mettais à parler de peinture
quand j'étais au collège ou au lycée en
mal mais parce que t'as pas été au
collège et au lycée à paris non ouais et
là c'est intéressant c'est que toi ça
fait un peu un chemin inverse en moi par
exemple je suis arrivé à paris pour mes
sites supérieur toi tu es passé d'une
enfance parisienne à une adolescence
rural oui oui complètement et après
c'est vrai que il n'ya pas le même accès
à la culture par rapport à l'offre des
musées et surtout surtout pas revoir au
tableau des grands peintres qu'on va
peut-être pas forcément enfin qu'on va
retrouver dans les grandes villes mais
moi j'étais vraiment à la campagne
campagne
l'offre culturelle là bas elle est plus
artisanal ou à propos du cinéma et des
spectacles
mais par rapport à l'art aux sculptures
ou au concert enfin dans ses réserves
mais où il va là par rapport aux oeuvres
picturales il ya pas beaucoup d'offres
en fait oui clairement quand je suis
arrivé je pense que je parlais en petits
pains voilà si je parlais de deux
tableaux ou des sujets tu avais presque
un complexe de supériorité on va dire
oui bah parce que par exemple en cours
de français il y avait des présentations
de tableau et moi souvent je connaissais
et donc il y avait un peu ce côté là
l'eau voilà royaume
ce que j'écoute à une socialisation
extrêmement avancé sur le commanditaire
en termes bourdieusien tu as un capital
culturel très élevé du fait de la
profession de ta mère qui est donc
professeur de français de littérature
donc un musicien de ton enfance petite
enfance parisienne
le fait d'avoir un capital intellectuel
et culturel très élevé quand on arrive
dans des régions où justement c'est pas
du tout la même socialisation qui a eu
lieu sacré est en effet un décalage ou
oui mais du coup ça tape a fait rejeter
tout cet héritage en amont la boutique
non tu l'as vu comme une fierté un peu
avec toi ou non même pas une vie art
parce que fierté ça fait un petit peu je
me sens au dessus de vous alors il m'a
du tout mais par contre j'ai par contre
j'ai remarqué que ça pouvait entraîner
un comportement agressif des autres on
pouvait se sentir peut-être à baisser ou
voile alors que moi c'est juste moi mais
c'est pas une fierté et puis en tant
qu'adolescent un enfant adolescent on se
rend pas compte que ça non et du coup le
compte instagram que talent c'est ce que
fait aujourd'hui tu n'es pas spécialiste
n'est pas travailleuses du milieu
culturel dans des milieux artistiques et
du coup elles commandent enfin comment
tu as eu envie de lancer le compte
instagram est ce que tu avais des
questions un peu sur ta légitimité à a
créé ce compte est ce que tu ne
s'atteint interrogé non parce que je me
suis toujours dit que
[Musique]
déjà les parle avec mon coeur et mes
émotions et ça et a que moi qui sait et
si je peux les partager et que on peut
les lire et que ça peut toucher tant
mieux mais donc voilà je ne pars pas
toujours dans des sujets très
intellectuelles ou scientifiques
et quand je le fais pas j'essaye de me
ressourcer plusieurs endroits et je fais
pas non plus une recherche biographique
énorme
enfin voila j'ai envie que ce soit
accessible à tout le monde en plus je
veux pas voilà écrire des pavés qui
serait finalement réservé qu'à une
partie qui ménage déjà dans un milieu
non et puis ce qui est sympa avec ton
compte c'est ce qui est assez différent
par rapport aux autres qu'on peut voir
sur instagram de deux peintures de
partage d'art etc
c'est que t'as pas forcément une
approche technique et que au contraire
c'est un peu l'art par la petite porte
par l'anecdote et il se trouve qu'il ya
quand même plusieurs anecdotes en tant
que l'aspirante sociologue donc jamais
de dire aspirante d'ailleurs ce que en
tant que doctorante en sociologie en
tant que donc doctorante en sociologie
il ya plusieurs fois ou dans tes posts
et j'ai trouvé ce set
cette pensée sociologique qui imprégnait
texte est ce que toi c'est quelque chose
que qui êtes intéressés que tu essaies
de pousser ou est ce que c'est un peu le
hasard de certains thèmes qu'ils
poussent à émettre des réflexions
sociologiques
je pense que la sociologie elle est dans
tous les sujets et part on est d'accord
donc ça je dirais que ça sort comme ça
en tout cas je me dis pas forcément de
thématiques al avance sur lesquels je
vais publier c'est juste une impulsion
et ou alors mon humeur du moment
donc parfois bah je vais je dire un
texte où je vais regarder un
documentaire qui va m'inspirer sur ciel
sujet là parfois enfin je suis je suis
très impliquée dans certains buts comme
la jud féministe et donc voilà je
parfois j'essaie de créer des ponts en
fait entre ce que peut nous faire
ressentir un tableau ce que nous dit un
tableau et des thématiques actuelles qui
m'intéresse voilà et parfois oui c'est
des thématiques de sociaux par exemple
vaille à un poste qui m'avait marqué
c'était sur la peintre versement les
eaux il me semble ouais qui était un
poste où justement suis un peu un état
des lieux
à la fois la représentation des femmes
parmi les peintres et de la
représentation des femmes en tant que
objet de la peinture que objets d'art
oui parce que bas comme je l'expliqué au
début les listes que j'ai dressé depuis
des années en fait il ya très très peu
de peintres femmes dans cette liste
parce qu en fait voilà pour moi ya pas
du tout une bonne représentation et ce
poste je les écris je me rappelle
c'était la fin de l'été je sais pas je
commençais à me dire mais vraiment en
fait ces tableaux y sont absolument
magnifiques et moi c'est que la deuxième
fois que je publie sur ma page un
tableau d'une femme et je me disais à la
fin j'ai une espèce de révolte qui monte
en moi et je me suis dit 'c'est
invisibilisation depuis des centaines et
des centaines d'années sur bas des
compositrices des peintres des poétesses
voilà qui m'était complètement effacée
par l'histoire avec un grand h ou soit
leur travail a été détruit soit il a été
volé et je me suis dit enfin c'est
tellement horrible parce que c'est un
manque de culture énorme faim quand on
se rend compte toute la richesse qui
existe déjà
culturellement si en plus le travail des
femmes n'avaient pas été volées
invisibilité on aurait encore un
patrimoine culturel
enfin encore plus grand que qu'une est
aujourd'hui avec un regard en plus
j'imagine différent puisqu'il ya ba plus
communément jeudi on parle du mail
guérissent du regard masculin mais
forcément si on vise ibiliz des artistes
non seulement féminine mais aussi issus
de minorités etc
c'est aussi un autre regard sur
l'esthétique sur la beauté et du coup
peut-être que dans la même époque dont
même courant artistique on aurait vu
d'autres manières de faire oui et en
plus je trouve qu'il ya le processus
d'identification
alors pour apprécier une oeuvre j'ai pas
forcément ou apprécier un livre j'ai pas
forcément besoin de m'identifier aux
personnages ou deux mais il ya quand
même un côté ou pas moi par exemple je
me suis enfin depuis que je suis petit
je pense que j'étais attiré par la
création mais je me suis jamais dit je
vais faire parce qu'en fait tous les
livres que j'avais lu et tous les tous
ces tableaux que j'avais vu les femmes
elles n'étaient pas les créatrices de
ses oeuvres et elle était plutôt les les
inspiratrice et du coup moi je me suis
plus constituer comme bats aussi voie la
plus à un objet d'esthétisme qui peut
inspirer ses hommes qui sont des génies
et voilà au lieu de me dire mais moi je
peux être une génie aussi je peux faire
des choses il n'est pas trop tard
évidemment mais je vais passer enfin mal
à s intéresser mon jouet forcément on se
met plus facilement en tant que femme
dans le rôle de la musque dans le rôle
de l'artiste en plus je sais pas si ça
peut avoir un lien mais toi ton père et
créateurs parmi les compositeurs il est
musicien et du coup tu as eu en plus
c'est au sein de ton foyer cette figure
de l'homme génie on va dire en quelque
sorte
et peut-être que ça en plus renforcé un
peu ce mais cet effet s'est enfin fait
drôle parce que bon là c'est personnel
mais dans mon histoire familiale depuis
ces dernières années
moi j'ai eu ces révélations un petit peu
comme quoi bah moi aussi je peux être la
créatrice et ma mère l'a également eu
elle qui a toujours vécu avec un 17
heures un génie musical et elle s'est
mise à écrire de la poésie et pour moi
c'est une très grande poétesse donc
j'espère qu'elle va franchir le passé
fait de la publication par exemple en
plus tu publies ses poèmes associé à ça
que j'avais à certains tableaux
je pense à un poste que tu as fait
qu'ils étaient en plus c'est très
émouvant parce que les deux oeuvres
littéraires et artistiques et enfin
picturale ce combiné très bien et un
tableau que j'avais découvert au musée
de bristol bah c'est le dernier enfin
l'adar fois j'étais allé au musée dans
le monde d'avant alors librement sans
masque j'étais en angleterre et donc à
l'ouest ce tableau à une sirène qui
emporte au marin dans les profondeurs et
j'ai associé bien poèmes de ma mère mais
oui en fait c'est fou parce que ce côté
de la représentation du fait de se
sentir représentés on ne trouve dans
tous les domaines et par exemple d'un
milieu universitaire le fait de voir a
maintenant de plus en plus de femmes
universitaires mais c'est quand même
quelque chose qui était lors de l'
exception jusqu'à très récemment et
encore maintenant la majorité des femmes
qui ont des thèses en sciences sociales
sont comme moi hors contrats non
rémunérés avec un espèce de plafond de
verre en temps de financement mais aussi
d'accès aux postes de professeurs des
universités qui est criant et forcément
d'avoir des femmes qui est son à ces
postes c'est essentiel parce que c'est
ce qui permet de nous dire qu'on va
pouvoir le faire
pour autant ça n'empêche pas évidemment
comme tu le disais d'être inspiré par un
plein de sociologues et masculin qui
écrit des ouvrages est très intéressant
et d'ailleurs et à tout le champ de la
critique féministe de grandeur
sociologie
donc ça ne dure qu al mabhouh du xterra
qui sont super intéressante et je pense
que dans le milieu de l'art tu pourras
nous en parler mais il ya eu aussi c'est
une nouvelle vague de jeunes historienne
de l'art et spécialiste de maquis ont
sorti des beaux-arts des jeunes artistes
etc qui proposait de revoir la façon de
construire les expositions par exemple
dans une perspective féministe notamment
le discours autour d'une oeuvre dans le
sens où on peut apprécier
on peut apprécier n'importe quelle
oeuvre du moment que le cartel enfin les
historiens et historiens de l'art et
arrive à la contextualiser dans son
époque
donc parce que par exemple il ya des
oeuvres qui sont magnifiques dans la
technique mais par exemple qui
représente un sujet complètement raciste
on veut dire ou alors complètement
misogyne mais en fait voilà quand on
voit ce tableau pour moi on peut en
apprécier la beauté l'esthétisme et tout
mais il faut absolument que ce soit
contextualiser et il faut garder une
vigilance sur le sujet et l'époque et le
peintre d'où ça vient enfin voilà pour
moi c'est important même si bien
évidemment ça l'émotion qu'on voit quand
on quand on voit quelque chose d'acquis
beau ou qui voilà qui nous touche ça on
ne peut pas la rue ni évidemment et moi
je trouverais ça triste de s'empêcher
d'aller enfin voilà d'apprécier des
tableaux mais il faut toujours
contextualiser pour moi en fait toute
oeuvre peut être montré à un moment où
elle est située
et toujours cette idée que ça témoigne
en fait au delà de de la beauté pure et
dure de l'oeuvre et encore la beauté est
un concept en sociologie qu'on apprend à
comprendre à avoir un petit peu de tout
ça bien etc
mais bref au delà de l'esthétisme pur de
réussir à ci dessus une oeuvre pour en
comprendre les tenants et aboutissants
historique en terme de mouvements
artistiques et serra c'est super
important et on abat en sociologie
tout ce qu'on avait les théories du
point de vue qui sont le fait que même
en sociologie pour montrer une réalité
qui est censé être objective pour
atteindre l'objectivité il faut
comprendre toutes les subtilités qui
entre dans le travail sociologique et ça
commence par la compréhension de son
identité par rapport aux personnes
auprès desquels on enquête donc la
théorie du point de vue c'est celle où
il faut créer affirmer son identité son
identité par rapport aux personnels qui
on en parle
par exemple si moi demain je fais mes
enquêtes sur mon sujet avec des
travailleurs agricoles en turquie c'est
pas même chose que si je me présente
comme sociologue dans la haute
bourgeoisie française
donc mon identité est changeante en
fonction du public que j'ai en face de
moi et tout ça c'est pour réussir à
atteindre quelque chose qui est plus
objectif et du coup dans le milieu
artistique
c'est un peu le même problème dans le
sang sont souvent une heure faisant
voilà cette oeuvre est belle c'est havel
digne d'être au musée d'orsay
mais on a aussi besoin de tous deux
contestent ce qui va autour et oui et du
coup sûr l'idée de la beauté je disais
justement quelle est en sociologie on
apprend à avoir que la beauté c'est un
fait social dont quelque chose qui est
construit qui n'a rien de naturel et je
trouve que la peinture justement nous
montre tout à fait de l'évolution de la
conceptualisation de la beauté et de la
dspe on considère comme la beauté comme
les normes de beauté
mon point de vue sur sa autant
évidemment c'est pesant ça peut paraître
pesant d'avoir été objectifs visés en
tant que femme voilà sur des millénaires
de peinture ou quasiment fin je ne sais
pas la fin il ya tellement de sujets de
peinture c'est un corps de femme
et oui c'est magnifique mais ça aurait
été bien aussi d'avoir un autre penchent
enfin voilà plus peut-être de cordes à
me représenter
mais en même temps les portes que ça
ouvre par rapport à l'art c'est que on
se rend compte que les critères de
beauté de ya 200 ans ne sont plus les
mêmes qu'aujourd'hui et on voit une
évolution de la beauté et ça ce
témoignage culturel historique par
rapport à la peinture fins que la
peinture à porte c'est génial on peut
dire que la photographie ça apporte ça
mais la photographie ça existe depuis
pas si longtemps à l'échelle de
l'humanité et la peinture pour le coup
moi c'est le premier biais de
communications depuis l'aube de
l'humanité
tout ce qui est pictural est visible en
terme de défense voilà est beaucoup plus
que l'écriture je pense oui parce que
c'est la question de la représentation
de ce qu'on considère comme la
perfection comme le corps idéal comme le
corps désirable aussi puisque les femmes
ont été objet de peinture puisque les
hommes de l'enquêté et
de voir l'évolution des codes sociaux en
termes de beauté ça peut aussi être une
arme très puissante pour je pense aider
les futures générations de jeunes femmes
à voir que les codes des beautés sont
quelque chose de tout à fait relatif
comme va dans les peintures
je parle de la renaissance le corps des
femmes était tout à fait différent de
celui que vont mettre en avant les
peintres au 19e et c'est beaucoup plus
de forme
on voit aussi que les enfin les endroits
qui sont censés être sensuelle enfin ne
sont plus les mêmes qu'aujourd'hui il ya
aussi toute l'histoire des grands
scandales que de la peinture et de la
représentation des femmes dans la
peinture
on pense évidemment à l'origine du monde
j ai un tableau qui a choqué maintenant
il est chaud qu en fait fin il enfin je
veux dire on peut le maintenant si on le
ressort ça va encore choqué des gens
alors que c'est un très vieux tableau
donc on voit que le sujet est
complètement et même le titre est
complètement à chocques enfin quand même
provocateur et voilà provocateur du coup
par rapport à ce que tu dis sur la
représentation le fait qu'on n'ait pas
besoin de s'identifier pour au peintre
ou à la peinture pour se sentir
représenté est capable enfin de prendre
comme ça de pouvoir réussir à se
projeter dans ces carrières ou dans
cette créativité est ce que tu peux nous
parler un peu plus de ce que tu en
penses de quel est le devoir qu'ont adc
de radware représenter plus de corps
plus de de mixité dans la peinture en
tant que artistes alors en fait je
dirais que je changerais un petit peu la
question parce que moi je pense que il
ya eu beaucoup
enfin que tout le monde a été
représentée mais je dirais que au musée
on valorise pas toujours on valorise
toujours les mêmes sujets ou toujours et
même de la question de qui accède au
panthéon
oui et qui est la naissance donc par
exemple
enfin je pense à la l'exposition le
modèle noir qui avait lieu au musée
d'orsay où il avait montré le tableau le
tableau célèbre de manet
olympia mais en fait enfin ce tableau
c'est une femme blanche qui est allongée
nue et est en fait enfin derrière il ya
une gouvernante noir et en fait le
tableau là il était montré et le cartel
faire la description c'était vraiment
centré autour de la gouvernante noir du
tableau qui fait autant partie du
tableau que cette muse blanche que cet
olympia blanche allongé sur le lit et
donc donc voilà aussi c'est une manière
que enfin je pensais les historiens les
historiens de l'art et puis ce qu'ils
occupent des expositions doivent enfin
voilà orienter un petit peu plus parce
que toutes les expositions seront
orientés et tout le linéaire fin comment
marche ce qu'on lit petit à petit fin on
oriente notre notre vision et notre
perception d'imposition des époques des
tel coup ça comme à la mode comme
interdits basse et des choix qui relève
aussi de sociologie pourquoi est ce
qu'on décide de mettre en avant le
modèle noir en 2019 je crois que c'était
l'exposition quelque chose qui aurait
été inimaginable quelques années
auparavant
moi je trouve que voilà on n'est pas
forcément obligé de de s'identifier à
une oeuvre pour l'apprécier comme je les
dis au début par contre l'identification
ça peut vraiment être une porte d'entrée
vers le monde de l'art et voilà moi je
sais que enfin il ya certains par
exemple ya certains romans enfin je
serai jamais rentré dedans si au début
je m'étais pas identifié et puis en fait
après ça m'a fait découvrir d'autres
catégories de romans et là je
m'identifiais plus du tout mais en fait
j'avais appris à apprécier l'oeuvre dans
sa globalité où l'auteur dans sa
globalité
enfin au final j'ai des amis qui était
jamais allé au musée avant ou alors très
très rarement hélas ils sont allés voir
cette exposition
donc c'est bien que ça a un côté hyper
intéressant et qu'il faut absolument
encourager encourager en fait à aborder
l'objet artistique par des points de vue
différents et au final c'est aussi un
peu ce que ce feuilleton compte
instagram je trouve c'est d'aborder
l'art par la petite porte par l'anecdote
par la porte dérobée même au delà de ça
c'est par un angle en fait qu'ils
n'avaient jamais été mis en avant qui
était resté un angle mort de l'approché
artistique de montrer qu'il ya d'autres
manières de comprendre la beauté et
l'esthétique et de voir aussi bas toute
la réalité qui a été dépeinte mais il ya
aussi le côté
de l'impression qu'on peut avoir et pour
moi c'est pas faut pas que la peinture
ou par exemple aussi l'opéra reste dans
un milieu élitiste comme si on devait
être éduqués pour ressentir des émotions
que cet art afin césar sont censés nous
enfin nous procure et c'est quelque
chose de physique aussi les émotions ne
sais pas c'est pas que quelque chose
d'intellectuels évidemment on prend du
plaisir à contextualiser à s'intéresser
et si on n'est pas habitué à ces
mécaniques l'air et ben on peut se dire
que l'oeuvre on peut pas se l'approprier
et elle ne va rien nous faire on peut se
sentir exclu de l'oeuvre alors que en
fait une oeuvre on l'a précise juste en
ouvrant son coeur et enfin voila moi je
vois vraiment choses comme ça et ces
voix là pour ça que si j'ai créé ce
compte c'est aussi pour partager
l'émotion avant tout et pas l'intellect
mais voilà même si oui c'est toujours en
plus mais voilà c'est pour moi c'est pas
la fibre première donc pour ce faire
n'hésitez pas allez vous aimez aux
commandes de charlotte faut qu'elle
puisse continuer d'inonder lougheed des
oeuvres magnifiques et toujours avec une
histoire super intéressante qui lui est
associée j'espère que cette discussion
avec charlotte vous a plus que ça vous
aura permis va d'écouter quelqu'un
parler d'art et de croiser cela avec la
sociologie
j'espère que ça vous a intéressé ces
failles le dos que j'aurais pensé par
sur cette chaîne donc mentir ça m'a
beaucoup intéressé merci beaucoup
avec grand plaisir franchement c'était
vraiment super intéressant j'espère que
ça vous a plu autant qu'à nous je
m'assieds vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner à partager la vidéo et à
faire vivre sociaux logos je vous
retrouve très vite sur ça c'est la
gauche
[Musique]